je m'appelle Tycho ytt je suis le réalisateur
de Thor Ragnarok finalement ce film parle
de Thor Ragnarok et de son voyage dans
certains endroits de l'espace extra-atmosphérique les gens
m'ont souvent demandé pourquoi êtes-vous devenu cinéaste
bien la raison principale voulait juste
impressionné ma mère et mon père et à  montre-
leur que je suis un perdant
j'obtiens ce que tu restes je peux réaliser des
rêves pas mes propres rêves mais les rêves des
autres je peux me rapprocher d'être
JJ Abrams je sais que tu le voulais comme fils
mais tu m'as eu je suis désolé je  Je ne suis pas JJ
Abrams, ils disent que j'aurais aimé que nous vous tirions JJ
Abrams aurait été tellement plus cool que
vous viviez sur Star Wars
eh bien, ça n'allait pas maman et papa, je
ne vous ai pas collé avec moi d'accord maintenant
jusqu'au fond-  graveleux pourquoi ai-je fait ce
film pour des félicitations et des abonnés sur
Twitter ce que je voulais vraiment faire avec
Thor était de capturer l'essence de Peter
Pan mais un peu de Terminator 2
un soupçon de jour de l'indépendance un peu de sur
Golden Pond avec une sorte  de ton de
plages mélangées avec ma belle dame donc
Arthur nous avons ac  J'ai compris qu'à la fin de
la journée, quand tout a été dit et fait, le
film parle de deux monstres, des
explosions de jolies dames, de beaux hommes,
il y a un Hulk, puis c'est le générique qui est
mort, tous les noms étaient les gens qui l'ont
fait, c'est ce que nous avons essayé de faire et je
pense que nous l'avons fait c'est ce que je voulais
réaliser avec ce film que nous avons craché de
Taika Waititi de Nouvelle-Zélande
hé ceci pour obtenir de l'aide non viens tu l'aimes
je déteste ça c'est de grands travaux chaque fois que
c'est humiliant avez-vous un meilleur
plan  non nous le faisons nous ne le faisons pas
obtenir de l'aide Chris et moi J'ai fait ce
voyage ensemble pendant sept ans et
c'est très différent de toute relation
que j'ai jamais eue avec un autre acteur
nous nous connaissons si bien et  Je pense que
d'une manière qui améliore tout dans
cette relation, nous avons un raccourci
et il me fait rire,
il est maintenant devenu un héros où il peut
se moquer de lui-même où il peut devenir
beaucoup plus conscient de son
environnement, nous voyons une porte qui est  été
trempé dans  le monde de Tony Stark, il a
pris des rythmes sarcastiques, il a le
sens de l'humour, l'
homme est puissant et utile à voir cependant
et il apporte cette attitude aux
stars avec elles et c'est cette version de
Thor que nous élaborons dans notre
film pour  montrez Chris comme la force comique
qu'il est vraiment
[Musique]
Sekar est gouverné par le Grand Maître joué
par Jeff Goblin et son fou
coloré et hilarant Je vous pardonne de la
vie
le Grand Maître est le négatif photo d'
Odin il est dans une figure de statut très élevé qu'il
fait  des choses avec des improvisateurs de grand maître disco
Je pratique maintenant
toute cette section qui m'inclut en tant que
grand maître jouant avec un groupe nous
voulions que ce personnage soit vraiment
mémorable et Goldblum est tout simplement parfait
je reviens à l'art que Dieu a demandé je
ne supporte pas  lui tout ce familier, il
est arrivé à Taiwan et en solo bleu j'ai demandé
joue un sperg yeux Dieu je vais vous dire
ceci et c'est honnête c'était le meilleur
moment que j'ai jamais eu
ne peut pas être Jackie Chan ouais c'était vraiment
amusant excitant et j'ai aimé ce que nous
faisions arrêtons là
tu sais ce que je me suis réveillé ce matin en
pensant à une exécution publique que j'ai fait
j'ai vraiment fait mais pour l'instant je vais me contenter de
ça toi doux petit qui va entrer en
premier
alors pendant que tu  're sur l'horloge cela signifie que le
code n'a-t-il pas compris que c'est le
signe universel c'était je n'ai pas clair pour l'
amour du ciel qu'avez-vous pensé de cela
il y a tellement de symboles universels c'en
est un qui n'est évidemment pas communicable
qu'est-ce que c'est mort
c'est le composer  en bas qu'est-ce
que c'est sortir pas plus petit ok ici comme la maladie
voici je voudrais un dessert ce serait
autre chose à dire ce serait je ne ferai pas
ça quelqu'un paie le bateau ne paie pas la
facture ce serait qui serait payer la
facture ce  est où est mon chèque où est mon
chèque s'il vous plaît ma joue
[Musique]
donc mon dernier colocataire est parti tout d'un
coup mais heureusement grâce à mon travail un
poste s'est présenté à Los Angeles donc j'avais
besoin de trouver un nouveau colocataire bonjour le
grand maître était le seul  qui
répond  J'ai lu mon annonce Craigslist ouais imaginez
que j'étais le seul à avoir de la chance au
début, je pensais qu'il était juste une autre
personne de type hollywoodien, puis j'ai réalisé qu'il
venait plus que probablement d'une autre planète.
J'aime en savoir plus sur votre culture. pourquoi
appelez-vous ce toast oui  Je viens de
Sekar c'est un refuge pour les choses perdues qui
sonne un peu poétique mais c'est vraiment une
sorte d'endroit fourre-tout et maintenant
sans vous ennuyer avec les détails que
j'avais autrefois et pendant une assez longue
période de
temps un assistant slash garde du corps nommé
topaze et maintenant vous savez que je cherche un
nouvel assistant et vous savez qui semble
parfaitement correspondre à la facture,
Darrell, il a beaucoup de
courage ce gars parce qu'il faut
beaucoup de travail pour construire comme ça pour
jouer en pensant
que ce qui est bien chez moi n'a pas été
affecté par sa grande célébrité et sa renommée
génial je m'ennuie pas mal de faire la
même chose et une fois que ça me semble trop
familier ou sûr je pense que ça devient moins
intéressant
il commence à faire quelque chose  c'est dans ce film
qu'il n'a jamais été capable de faire il
recrée le personnage eh bien
c'est tellement génial elle est là
partout euh ouais je vois que tu t'es
familiarisé avec notre
disque d'obéissance c'est une
de mes petites inventions au fait  tu sais que certaines personnes
trouvent que c'est une sorte de promenade érotique avec moi
Je vais te dire quelque chose
disque d'obéissance Je n'ai jamais été fou de ce
nom J'étais censé être un espace réservé
jusqu'à ce que je puisse penser à quelque chose de mieux
mais tout le monde a commencé à appeler  leur
obéissance est ce que les gars les gars
voici ce que je veux savoir qui êtes-vous
choisissez que je n'ai rien entendu mais
n'étaient-ils pas comme des étincelles de vos
doigts comme des éclairs peut-être vraiment
le chalet du cousin oh bon là il
est hé parce que nous  presque ne pouvait pas ne pouvait pas
te trouver ce qu'il cachait hmm donc je
dois admettre ce que tu as fait
Carlo ce que tu as dit ce n'était qu'un petit
chameau pourquoi l'as-tu fait un petit chameau
jeu jeu je ne sais pas ce que cela
signifie
jouer avec e  e chameau Oh faisons du camping
tu viens de dire que c'était du camping il n'y a pas
si mal que le
camping est mauvais mais ce que tu fais vraiment
je pariais sur la mort
travaillaient sur des gâteaux et des
techniques et ce genre de
trucs et de tours et de trucs tous les jours
il y a quelque chose qui est plus facile et
quelque chose qui est plus difficile nous voulions
trouver un style qui semble différent de
la façon dont vous voyez la plupart des femmes se battre
et filmer en général je le ferais  dire qu'elle se
bat comme un garçon sauf que cela diminue
le fait qu'elle se bat juste comme une
femme vraiment très forte Tessa s'est
jetée là-dessus de la manière la plus
extraordinaire juste un
engagement incroyable envers la physique de la
partie à
la minute où elle a ouvert la porte Wow
quelqu'un a  une histoire Tessa était si
convaincante et puissante et mystérieuse
que nous avons tellement parlé à Hollywood
de la représentation des femmes et nous avons
vraiment besoin  des rôles de stand-up forts pour les
femmes, mais nous avons aussi besoin de femmes qui sont en
conflit et qui ne sont pas si géniales,
nous avons besoin d'une représentation à tous
les niveaux pour que ce méchant soit
présenté d'une manière aussi forte, c'est
vraiment excitant
J'ai eu un plaisir incroyable à jouer  avec elle
parce que je pense que ses capacités sont si
surprenantes et si inhabituelles qu'elle n'est pas
simplement sinistre en fait en tant que personne
qui a joué le méchant dans ces films,
je comprends que la responsabilité est
qu'elle a une présence énorme qu'elle peut
exprimer physiquement ou verbalement, elle a juste
ça  -mouvement kilter de son
personnage, j'ai été complètement aveuglé par
certains des moments les plus heureux qui ont
attiré les gens vers quelque chose de bien
[Musique]
Korg joué par Taika Waititi est
une réponse incroyable, c'est tellement drôle parce que
je n'arrêtais pas de dire qu'il jouerait quelqu'un dans  ce
film tu sais ouais tu vas jouer la
chance dans ton cœur aujourd'hui
je pense que nous croyons que tu peux le faire ce perroquet
est extrêmement fascinant pour moi c'est un
homme géant fait de r  ock stone and granite
and opal qui sait ce qu'il y a au-delà c'est
une femme en chair et en os
m'approchera ils ont dit que nous voulons vraiment changer
la franchise que nous voulons prendre tomber dans une
nouvelle direction nous voulons avoir une
aventure et le faire  drôle je vais
dominer les montagnes et enterrer mon épée au
fond d'un spa
donner une seconde je me souviens de la première
fois que j'ai lu le script que j'ai fait
rire à haute voix ou pas je jure que je ne bouge même pas
ça fait juste cette ozone à droite
du personnage  Je me sentais différent
[Musique]
Hé, j'ai trouvé que la nourriture avait l'air vraiment bonne,
trop bonne, j'essayais juste de me concentrer.
J'ai raté la mort de mon père parce que je me
concentrais sur mon destin mais je n'ai pas raté
la mort de mon père parce qu'il a été
assassiné juste devant moi par ma
sœur dont je ne savais même pas qu'elle existait
parce qu'elle m'était cachée mon
Toute la vie a l'air terrible comparé  mon fils
n'a rien à voir avec ce que tu
traverses et ma famille
coûterait de se battre entre nous alors que
tout le monde en souffre non j'étais des
dieux et des chambres et bien c'est
ma sœur hella tu sais si je ne l'ai pas fait
veto car tu pourrais tuer ta sœur
pensé sans son casque tu n'es pas
le gars qui martèle ici Dumbo ne ressemble pas
à un compliment c'est totalement un
compliment Dumbo Dumbo sonne comme si
tu m'appelais Dumbo encore et
encore
Dumbo à la maison dit une fois  plus je te dirai si
tu penses qu'elle peut voler parce qu'il y a une
plume magique et puis il perd sa
plume quand Danny se rend compte qu'il n'avait
rien à voir avec le fait qu'il vole du tout l'
homme plume d'où je viendrais était que
moi tout le temps  tu vas à la queue
n'a même rien dit nous sommes là ouais
ouais débarrasse-toi de ça
c'est juste cette chose magique qui
s'est produite ce genre d'idée vraiment risquée donnant
vie à tout ce monde et je
pense avec Thor encore Hemsworth devant
et il y avait t  sa très gentille petite
version de science-fiction d'une image Marvel peut
chaque film qu'il a développé une grande affection
pour la Terre et les humains et la première fois que
nous l'avons vu quand il était arrogant, cela peut
être ce grand type de force, de
connaissance et de pouvoir avec  lui, mais il y a
aussi une sorte d'enfant naïf
au centre, c'est bien d'avoir
ce contraste et ce mélange la plus grande
préoccupation est que leur bien-être de ce
monde et lui
regarde beaucoup plus loin dans l'univers  pour
s'assurer que cette menace ne consume pas
ce monde aussi bien
vous